hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel today i'm going to give
you guys
a little bit different of a video i'm
not going to react to anything
because i've been traveling i'm in utah
right now
and i just i don't feel like setting up
my camera and my laptop i don't feel
like doing it so
i still want to give you guys some
content so i want to talk about the five
themes that i've noticed listening to
rap music
before i start don't forget like comment
and subscribe especially subscribe i'm
almost to 10 000 followers or i'm not
followers
subscribers it'd be pretty cool to hit
10k here's the five
themes that i've noticed now if you guys
don't agree with me you can't be mad
this is just
what i've noticed you're welcome to
correct me if i'm wrong but there's five
things that songs are about
number one flexing on how cool you are
i'm the [ __ ] i'm the goat just
i am cool and the under this theme is
like a sub
theme if i'm also brave i'm not afraid
to shoot anybody i'm
thug like whatever you want to say like
different ways of just
validating coolness theme number two is
weed that's it not much more to it
theme number three i get women
some way of saying that like i can sleep
with a lot of girls
it could be i can [ __ ] your [ __ ] that's
possibly one
it also could be you know the hoes love
me like the [ __ ] love
sosa theme number four is i have
money now they can show that they have
money in a variety of ways
they can either show watches and stuff
in the music video
or they can say things like i got bands
i spent usually an absurd amount of
money on something like a watch
or a chain like to me not a great
investment
i don't think it makes you look cool at
all but
people can spend their money how they
want it's just a theme that i've noticed
nobody asked for my opinion except for
those of you subscribed so if you don't
agree
that's fine but you subscribe to my
channel so you're already here
number five is referencing the reference
things about like gang
activities and it's not always what you
think we're going to talk about the ops
i learned that the opposition can either
be the cops
or it can be like the opposing gang so
they'll make a lot of references
about like the opposing gangs and like
just different stuff that's going on
also like a trap house oh and they're
always gonna
snitch oh my gosh this is the most
important part though snitches
are bad not good like
if you snitch you might have a lot of
people mad at you
because you're not supposed to do that
they do not respect snitches
that's like the five themes that i've
noticed i'm gonna keep this series going
i'm sure there's gonna be more let me
know you think i'm right you think i'm
wrong either way
comment below do not forget to subscribe
i think i'm learning a lot i think i'm
getting pretty smart here so
don't forget i'm gonna talk to you guys
later
you